[Music]
what that tells me a whole lot of people
are about to die hey everybody its
charlie happy comic-con week we've
finally got confirmation on what's going
on with the birds of prey movie so you
probably heard about versions of this in
various characters that are gonna pop up
Black Canary Batgirl now we finally
learned what the actual roster is going
to be in what's going on with the
villain because you may have heard
Margot Robbie's comments about how they
wanted to do an r-rated girl gang film
and there are a couple limitations when
you want to do in r-rated DC Comics film
with the characters that you use so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Comic
Con videos there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on the video you know name a new
winner at the end of this here's what we
get to the big stuff though the roster
obviously Harley Quinn Margot Robbie is
going to be a producer on the film
Helena Bertinelli Huntress
as of the beginning of the events of the
movie she will have been a vigilante
operating out of Gotham Cassandra Cain
who's been a couple different characters
in the comics I'll explain why she's
sort of the Batgirl of the team but how
they're probably going to handle Batgirl
because they're still doing a Batgirl
movie with Barbara Gordon so it sounds
more confusing that it is but I'll talk
about Cassandra Cain cuz she's a special
case in a second then Renee Montoya who
has not become the question yet during
the events of this movie she's just
gonna be a detective the role you would
expect them to give Gordon during a
normal Batman film like you need to have
some sort of police presence with all
these vigilantes operating out of the
city and of course probably the biggest
one people have been talking about for a
long time
Black Canary the Dinah Laurel Lance
version of Black Canary her mother also
named Dinah will have been the original
version of Black Canary her father Larry
Lance is a former member of the Gotham
City Police Department most of you are
probably vaguely familiar with the way
arrow has treated the Black Canary
character there have now been three
different characters to wield the mantle
so it's a bit of a mess on that TV show
for the benefit of the movie universe
just pretend like that didn't happen if
the film goes well this version of Black
Canary will henceforth be the version
that you see pop up in any other films
so many of the movies are pulling from
the new 52 right now I wouldn't be
surprised if this did the same thing too
but what the rumor is is that the
villain they've confirmed it's a Batman
villain but the unconfirmed part of the
rumor is that it's gonna be David Kane
Cassandra Kane's father who she has sort
of a racial ghoul type relationship with
or say like ravager in Deathstroke here
is your legacy
here is your inheritance the League of
Assassins yes grandfather they will be
yours to command to make certain the
earth abides and natural contentment
give this crazy mercenary father who's a
former member of the League of Assassins
who has a daughter trains her to be his
weapon of mass destruction then tries to
push her down a path the same way that
Rachel Ghul and Talia tried to push
Damien down a league of assassins paths
but in the same way that Batman sort of
takes Damien in and tries to be a good
influence he does the exact same thing
for Cassandra Cain when she becomes the
next version of Batgirl now she's had
three different comic-book names in her
ten years she's been Batgirl she became
black bat during the new 52 then more
recently a younger version of the
character was introduced during rebirth
and she was called orphan and sort of
came up through this vigilante training
program so I'm expecting them to go more
with the new 52 version the reason why I
don't think that she's going to be back
girl during the film is is because
they're doing that Barbara Gordon
Batgirl film and it's fairly easy to
assume why they're not using Barbara
Gordon Batgirl in this birds-of-prey
movie because under normal circumstances
you would expect them to go with the
biggest characters and she would be one
of those but like I said at the
beginning of the video Margot Robbie
pitched this film to the studio as an
r-rated girl gang film and I don't think
that Warner Brothers wants to go that
hard core with the Barbara Gordon
character I think it sounds like they
want their Batgirl Barbara Gordon film
to be more pg-13 remember when Joss
Whedon was on the project and then said
sorry I didn't have a story like six
months went by and he was like I don't
have a real story so he left the project
I have so many things to say about her
very excited to see a girl in the CAO
anybody I feel like I want I'm creating
this character I'm in a dialogue with
her and then we'll see who joins that
later on name in mind that you thought
it for the part I doubt it'll be a man I
think
somewhere where you go and find back
there all any caster now to be fair that
was after all the Justice League blow
back that may have had something to do
with it but then he later clarified what
he meant when he said that he didn't
have an actual story for Batgirl what he
said was is that the story that he
wanted to do wasn't the direction that
Warner Brothers wanted to go in after
all this Justice League blowback so it
sounds like his take on the character
was more dark more gritty and Warner
Brothers was like you know what we're
kind of done with that we want to go
into more positive direction at least
with that character because they do have
the DC dark label in that new Joker film
with Joaquin Phoenix which I will
explain in a second because that's even
more confusing so I think the minute the
studio was on board for a smaller
budgeted but r-rated girl team-up film
Barbara Gordon was out of the mix like
okay we'll just save her for another
film that's totally very different the
good news in there though is that if it
is gonna be genuinely hardcore you're
gonna get a hardcore version of Black
Canary
I think caity lotz was on the cusp of
that on the arrow TV show but for
whatever reason they decided to kill her
off and then spin her off to her own
show as white canary and she's on
legends of tomorrow now so I don't think
that they've referenced her time as
Black Canary in a long while but she
still to me is the best TV version of
Black Canary so far she's pleading
that's not deep good more scars
speaking of mordor out yeah I eat it but
take a province Afghanistan good I know
my wounds goodnight Algiers I've never
been hit by a grenade all those scars
you know be hit by a grenade arrow knife
knife lot of bullets no grenades I got
myself a new bullet for those of you
asking about that new Joker film with
Joaquin Phoenix and Todd Phillips that's
the Martin Scorsese produce one that's
going to be part of their DC dark label
their rumor to be doing The Killing Joke
it's supposed to be an origin story for
the character which I know raises a lot
of red flags why would you even want an
origin story for the Joker part of the
charm of the character is that he
doesn't have a definitive backstory that
was the beauty of Heath Ledger's Joker
is that every time he told his origin
story to someone in the film it was a
differ
story so you never knew if he was being
honest you remind me of my father but
like I said supposed to be Killing Joke
it's on the DC dark label they're
calling that sort of like their boutique
for really dark DC films that are not
part of the DC EU so for the time being
until he officially leaves Jared Leto is
still DC EU joker they still have a
movie plan with him at some point which
I know is gonna get really confusing but
he also just signed on to be Morbius
inside Sony's spider-verse that'll
crossover with the venom movie so the
film's not vaporware and they wind up
making it then he's gonna be both DC and
Marvel character but I think the idea is
is that it seems like he's slowly on his
way out is the Joker in this new Sony
deal is just hedging his bets like okay
you're not gonna do any more Joker films
with me fine I'll go make some creepy
films with Sony in their spider-verse
so I wouldn't worry too much about that
right now the real talk of this week is
gonna be like Young Justice all the new
TV trailers and of course the Aquaman
trailer there supposed to be some Wonder
Woman 2 footage and some Shazam footage
but we'll see about that
they might not reveal all of it the
Aquaman 1 is the only confirmed trailer
that they'll be dropping online so of
course whatever ends up happening I will
totally do videos for it congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Adrienne
Alvarez please email me on the back end
of my channel new flash season 5 posting
tomorrow while you wait for everything
click here for a brand new Aquaman
trailer preview and click here for brand
new Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]